这种父亲他不能称之为父亲，
他其实本质上是一个动物，
是一个禽兽，
那既然他跟我不是同类，
他都不是人类，
我为什么要跟他有瓜葛？
我是去年二四年刚刚毕业的，
然后毕业了之后父母要求我回老家，
我就回老家了，
老家是在湖北的一个地级市，
今年九月份的时候，
我妈妈就是出车祸打折受伤，
他出车祸之后呢，
因为要照顾我妈，
所以我就跟我父亲的相处时间会变长很多。
在今年的十月份发现我爸在跟着别人吵期负，
但是其实他手上没有那么多钱，
我就自己想办法去查这个事儿，
包后也利用了我妈的一些人脉关系去查，
然后发现我爸在外面大概有130多万的欠款，
全都是就是朋友之间的借贷，
我就反头去问了，
我妈妈，
我妈说其实我爸已经有将近半年没有在我家用了，
相当于他就是在家白吃白喝，
我现在的问题主要是有这几个，
第一个就是我爸这个事其实已经不围了，
因她已经跟我们交代了，
他这边已经能废掉了这170多个给我们自己来填，
家里面的资产其实并不多，
我们家现在零收能力是妈妈是个白大褂，
现在的第一个事就是我劝我妈妈离婚，
但我妈一。
一直一打岔，
因为我父亲是在200809年的时候，
他确诊了一个广发性焦虑，
说是不能离婚，
我不知道有没有这个说法，
我没有听说过，
我只听说过，
如果他是属于精神分裂，
如果是属于无行为能力人，
他如果要离的话，
是需要他的监护人去同意的，
也就是说要他的父母去同意的，
有民事行为的人是可以离的，
这是一个事儿，
我们第二个事就是想要咨询一下您关于我妈妈，
因为就是查到这个事情的话，
对我妈的打击挺大的，
那我知道我父亲的欠债是和我无关的，
一代不表是他们夫妻共同的一个欠款，
跟我无关了，
但是对我妈打击挺大，
我都会去考虑一个有他道德的事情，
因为我爸就是瞎投资，
这个事情已经不是第一次了，
基本上他每个5~10年，
他就会在屋里面亏个大几十万或者大几百万这个样子会出去，
所以我是想跟他断亲的，
我发现我断亲的话，
我妈就会成为一个血恶，
我得养我妈，
然后我妈就会把钱转给我爸，
有没有一种可能，
跟你爸断了亲了之后，
只给你妈买衣服，
只给你妈买吃的，
只给你妈发快递，
暂时不给他钱，
都物质事了是吧？
对呀，
我比如说我想给他买点五常大米，
我看一下单就寄过。
去了，
我想给他买点什么好吃的啊，
什么牛肉干，
我咔一下单就寄过去了，
我不给他钱，
那我给了他钱的话，
他就会成为我爸爸乱花钱的这样一个血包，
我跟着我还有一个可能也是法律相关的问题哈，
因为我养的有猫猫狗狗，
所以我一直想了，
有一套我自己的房，
去年工作一年，
就是相当于把这个钱给挣到了，
我就把我自己的首付给付了，
我的父母是没有丝毫助力的这么一个状态。
现在的一个问题就是我爸不知道是从哪里来的渠道，
他知道了我的小区门牌号，
其他都知道了，
他就反复过来骚扰我，
就是他来敲门离不开他的腿，
有一个前妻条病，
就是我现在没办法和我父亲相处，
就是我看到他了之后，
我会心脏疼，
因为我小时候我被家暴的比较严重，
而且我是被我亲亲亲过的，
我又打不过他，
像今天早晨控制他，
就早晨8点他就来门口了，
然后说要进来姑娘，
像你这样的爸爸呢，
你有一个方法，
就是把你现在买的这个房子啊，
租给一个男的，
你自己再出去租房子，
什么时候时间合适了呢，
这个房子也可以卖出去，
你千万别动不动就是想着买房子，
我就是租房子，
我非常子有，
我狡兔三窟，
任何时候你找到。
我的话，
我第二天我就搬走，
我不能买房子了，
你买房子的话，
假设啊，
离个108000里，
他怎么查都查不到，
可以买，
如果离得近，
就他一个小时他就找到你了，
这个地方不要买，
比如说你跑到海南去，
你买一套房，
他怎么查怎么找，
怎么问，
他都找不着，
可以买，
不是亲生父亲，
那这个事情就是我不能通过报服务呀什么的事情去解决吗？
你报一次你就知道了，
不会管的是吧，
这话我不能在直播间说，
你报一次你就知道了，
我给你的方案就是最好的方案就是离得远，
就是拉黑，
不要发朋友圈，
不要告诉以后你在工作单位上也不要告诉别人你的老家是哪里的，
你们只有用这种方式才有可能真正跟他断的掉，
但凡你想联系一下表姐，
联系一下二舅，
联系一下姨妈的话，
不联系，
不要让他们知道你在哪里工作，
包括你的初中同学，
包括你的高中同学，
不联系，
如果实在要好的话，
你可以去他那里玩，
不要让他来你这里玩，
不要让任何人知道你的具体的门牌号，
我明白了，
嗯，
那好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
你们不要以为这样的父亲实在愿意相信，
这样的父亲一抓一大把，
你去看看那个安全官爸把，
就这种父亲，
他不能称之为父亲，
他其实本质上是一个动物，
是一个禽兽，
那既然他跟我不是同类，
他都不是人类，
我为什么要跟他有瓜葛？
像刚才那个姑娘，
我还有几句话我想跟你讲，
如果你能成长为一个善良的，
有同理心的、
公平观念的，
一个正直的人，
那你就非常牛叉了。
为什么你克服了基因，
你对抗了基因，
你战胜了基因，
你多牛叉，
所以你这辈子只要你善良，
只要你有同理心，
只要你正直，
你就是个成功的人，
谁能懂我这个点记得点赞关注哦。